to let me
beat some of the stuff that that link
can throw out with her stances but also
finally people are realizing how strong
cuny myth is i've been saying it for a
long time and people like no she's not
that good her nose are kind of whack
she is very strong people even rating
her like we've seen the taylor's come
out from the koreans rating her higher
than zafina and other characters so like
she's very strong man let's see what
museum has here man well yeah she's
definitely i i
like i know about the 2-2 stuff like
for the wrong reasons
getting hit by everything nice
a great punishment they threaded that
one
yeah
he's backing up together okay nice that
now that kunai is um i think that move
is very good honestly yeah it's like a
full screen instant
um
basically yeah yeah in certain scenarios
let's say for example if you're playing
versus like a an akuma or a geese or
something and they throw out fireballs
the the kunai is so quick and it's like
you said it covers pretty much full
screen um you'll be able to punish it so
in certain scenarios it's a good move to
throw and it can catch out your movement
very easily at max range or even at far
range uh it doesn't she doesn't come in
enough for you to punish yeah so it's
actually safe for certain ranges yeah
definitely i know way too much about
that move the forward and kuna i don't
know did you get the cuny mr treatment
yeah uh
please
i've got the i got the kuna mitsu
treatment with the adnan laughs
oh boy all right here we go
shout out okay you
cancel that goes for me trying to mix up
a little bit
oh as you say about the the kunai oh
that was a big opportunity for whiff
punish there
okay very patient in a minute
okay can you use that
oh oh big launch and this could
potentially be the round against the
right combo okay
a little bit um didn't calculate the
wall flat properly oh boy oh boy
nice nice good stuff masood guess the
round
lovely
i wonder why he chose cuny
all right no okay that wasn't a punish
but good stuff anyway um
or was it because it's a knee i don't
know yeah i might say that i think those
ones are weird it's a bit of a weird one
okay get the flip over here what's the
mix up
about to get towards to be very careful
airborne
oh my god i don't even know what that
move was
i'm okay yeah you're going for the
stance okay no punch on the hot knees
unfortunately
goes for the mid option back turn
forward one plus two masseuse now one
round away from taking the first match
okay just backing up
just he's just whipping the down is that
down four twos right
yeah
he wants him to run into it
good 10 frame punish back 10 throw
that's not mix-up
okay
yeah okay again visitor yes the throw
yeah see that's not mixed it wasn't
second tag two like link had a legit
back 10 throw mixer but she doesn't have
it anymore yeah nice yo some of your own
medicine you're not going to kill though
oh definitely don't drop it
but is it he is in a great position but
need to be very careful with the race
drive but yeah no it just happens just
keeps it nice and simple with the down
four fight
yeah from crouch down four
okay nice
sweep
oh
it's unfortunate
let's go ah nice good good launch lovely
lovely good dropping the combo
it's getting a little bit scrappy now
all right show me some sidestep threes
nice punish
can i get to the walls gonna keep it
nice and simple no chops the combo
it's really unfortunate here oh that's
-14 good punish
okay
bruh
okay okay
nice good punish
nice great i'm just wow turn four
is that guaranteed doctor kind of maybe
it could be guaranteed because she was
back turned as well yeah no she's better
so in that situation um
they nerfed it as well so when you do
that one throw and it broke i think you
were neutral it was both guys were
neutral in that situation now i think
you're minus but that back 10 launcher
was not guaranteed you could you
definitely could have turned around yeah
um
and even has moves of her own from back
ten cuny mitsu has her own kind of uh
you know a back turn that she does um
and she could have probably counter hit
that but that was a great read
but yeah i would like i would like to
see some side step threes from ling in
that much what do you think bubsy you
know the sweet the launcher size of
three yeah what do you think
um
it is um
kind of
seeable i
wow is it though is it is it really
though i don't know on this five bar
connection do you think so what do you
guys think at home do you guys think we
should see some ling size tip threes i
would i would personally love to see
something but it is what it is that the
ghetto mixed up size it free cancel it
into bat turn back down four yeah the
classic kind of classic you want to see
those you're bringing it to the streets
now
yeah leave them online street mix-ups
yeah that
ah
bring it to the superman the market you
get me
you can make it to the suit man but yeah
um
let's get into our next match
and is he going to switch characters is
he going to go to the um the the kazoo
now he's going for the geek ass um
interesting huh
this is a match that i am very
unfamiliar with
it's a matchup that used to be okay for
gigas i thought like um hey we know
jamie from ireland right now farfall and
he he was very strong versus ling he
used to do he had options you know down
back two and down for one these kind of
things could really shut down ling but i
feel like ling has just been buffed
quite a bit and and has the tools needed
to beat gigas now you know yeah um so
let's see what happens here gigas from
i'm not really familiar with so it'll be
interesting for me to learn i always
like learning
yeah and of course that down to minus 14
so the standing three from um from ling
will launch it
[Music]
oh boy nice
too okay now he's just applying that
pressure using those plus frames
not letting him get anything started
oh okay nice pops out
rage drive
this is just not going to be the round
sorry yeah i lied to everyone
that um scale damage at the end with the
spike into back turn for mohammed mishma
from jordan representing here
nice
oh
okay on points oh the candy roll
this is not looking good from a suit at
all okay no that doesn't work and get
just got pigeon legs oh boy yeah okay
here we go
i'm gonna get full conversion out of
this does have the ratios of additional
damage okay is that gonna hit it yeah
it did it no it didn't it didn't check
roll
that wasn't again that wasn't guaranteed
there
yeah
he's pulling out all the stops there man
he's pulling out all the stops
okay now get the prop up there
here just using all right using that
movement trying to get no
oh my god but you know in the moment
i think he's going through the gigas the
the move list he must have it like on
his side he's like okay what's the next
move uh yeah down back to down four
three okay what's the next one
nice
nice low power
okay
one hit away guesses correctly
wow
gets it anyway in the end
yeah right a very entertaining set there
very eventful
first or two with uh masood and um
muhammad but masood gonna finish with
seventh place not a bad showing at all
for him
but he's out the tournament now and uh
yeah we're gonna see we're gonna still
be seeing some jordanian tekken action
here in this uh bracket
yes